[Music]
you might think I've seen a lot the show
proud family based on what I said at the
beginning of my Disney Afternoon review
what's this on the prop family nobody
this is the prop Amelie long around but
the truth is I've never really seen any
of those show as those more just to make
a joke work I am somewhat aware of what
Pratt family is though if I visited
someone the Henke is I was always a show
that was on at the background so I know
a little bit about it there's a girl
named penny
yeah I don't really know too much else
outside of that the reason I bring this
up is because I'm not exactly an expert
on whether or not the proud family movie
is faithful to the Pratt family show I
just kind of assumed the show was kind
of like goof troop or suburban antics
mixed with cartoons a meanness but let
me tell you if it's anything like the
film I just saw this must have been one
of the craziest shows out there because
this movie was weird but luckily though
in all the best ways it opens with
probably the strangest mad scientist
I've ever seen in anything he has a nose
that keeps falling off and his master
plan is to create a race of peanut
people yeah peanut people he even has a
little peanut sidekicks the problem is
when he makes these peanut people they
don't last very long but he comes across
the proud family whose father named
Oscar is working on a food preservative
that multiplies food yeah this never
comes back again but it also makes the
food taste awful so the higher-ups don't
listen to him multiply food and you're
getting ramping just because it tastes
bad come on take that you can work with
it somehow but the mad scientist is
happy because that preservative he can
use to preserve his peanut people so he
sets up a phony contest that he says the
family won and flies them out to his
Island it's going to be a thing in these
Disney Channel movies isn't it but
things of course go loony as Oscar
discovers the mad scientist scheme and
he makes clones of the family
the clones end up going back to their
town accidentally taking the real penny
and the real family is stuck on the
island with clone penny absolutely none
of them are aware that they have the
wrong penny but the real penny actually
seems to like the clone father but he's
confused why her mother is suddenly
talking like a gangsta teen
sister what's the fun one mama after
seeking phone and also puzzled why her
dad suddenly has an obsession with hot
dogs and so are we for that matter
without giving anything away the story
goes so insane and so ridiculous that it
actually starts to make sense they
actually do have a reason why the mad
scientist is obsessed with peanuts and
when it's revealed it's so absurd you
can't help but kinda buy it maybe that's
the best way to explain this movie so
crazy that you can't help but enjoy it
Paul the characters are legitimately
charming and likable I especially liked
hearing Tommy Davidson again I don't
think I've seen him since in living
color I remember he had such this great
energy in this fast way of talking it's
great to hear him in the father
character if it was moving out here do
have anyone it'll be me hey of course I
would bring you with me honey the
animation ranges from cheap to
impressive to cheaply impressive it's
not like it has a ton of motion but the
still shots that they choose to freeze
on have a real Chuck Jones quality tool
they're just creep hoses and great
expressions even if they're not moving
they feel alive they have these great
designs that really lend themselves to
being bent and twisted and kind of like
a good comic strip or even though
they're frozen you can sense the
movement that led them to that pose it's
actually very cleverly done there's also
kind of a nice connection between penny
and her father they have a bit of a
falling out early on but I like that the
story doesn't necessarily take it in all
the places you think it's gonna take it
oh the cloned dad is gonna be too mean
as she realizes what a good father she
had right actually no she really likes
the clone dad it takes a really long
time in a long series of circumstances
to make her realize how important her
real bed is again it's strange but it's
somehow really works so again is this
movie representative of what the proud
family is about or is it too zany or not
zany enough I'm not really sure all I
can say is I had a lot of fun watching
this movie I liked the crazy story I
liked the adorable characters I don't
like how the animation cuts corners but
in such a creative way a way that
surprisingly looks great it leads to a
lot of great line work bizarre
definitely but also definitely a lot of
[Music]
you